after talk with my dad now i know what i
tell brendan
and when it moved
i try live here and i try help
but ah it's not working i started
staying at my kitchen i tired not touch
stuff i'm tired be alone here i'm tired
go sneaky
room like i'm baby i'm done
brandon i know brandon working right now
but i need to talk with him
i can wait talk with him later i need
now
hey you hear me yeah
i don't want to live here what i don't
want tech
animals i don't want to take care of all
what happened here
i hate i hate
this place well you know why i'm dirty
i'm look like
pig what is what is drink what's making
you so upset because brendan
i don't want to stay here
i won't leave i won't leave now i won't
leave now i don't want your parents say
i need gold
this i need to do this i won't leave
now you hear me
no no no no no no i say i say
brandon can you just
like talk about this later when i'm not
at work
i won't talk now
okay now i feel i have mistake
i come america and not see what i won't
see
what brandon promised me
brandon i serious i don't want you say
i'm fixing next you forget about this
and next you say
tomorrow tomorrow i don't want first off
i don't understand your phobia of like
animals
i not go america clean animals i not go
i didn't bring you here to clean animals
brandon i try but not
working brandon this makes me crazy this
makes me
angry
i won't leave now brendan not tomorrow
not after summer now
if you not go brandon i go russia you
understand this